[Applause]
for two decades Kobe Bryant rose above
every challenge that came his way in
basketballs elite league the NBA one of
the game's all-time greats he spent his
entire career with the Los Angeles
Lakers winning the NBA championship on
five occasions Bryant also won two
Olympic gold medals for the United
States is a giant in the sports world it
goes far beyond the NBA goes far beyond
basketball he is a worldwide a giant in
sports is hard-pressed to find anyone
that doesn't know Kobe he was bigger
than life he is one of the biggest most
well known NBA players of all time after
Michael Jordan he is one of the players
that made the NBA into a global sport
and took it into this next century after
excelling on the court at high school in
Philadelphia Bryant opted to skip
college and signed his first NBA
contract aged just 17 at the time of his
debut in the 1996 to 1997 season he was
the youngest player ever to appear in an
NBA game he more than lived up to that
early promise famously teaming up with
Shaquille O'Neal to win three
consecutive championships with the
Lakers in the early 2000s I adored basic
Bryant retired in 2016 and his post
basketball career had only just begun he
won an Oscar for the animated short film
dear basketball when he scored his final
NBA points in 2016 he was third on the
all-time scoring list only on Saturday
was his mark passed by a present-day
great LeBron James Bryant's final social
media post congratulated James on
continuing to move the game forward
something Bryant had done throughout his
own career
[Applause]
well that sports presenter Andy
Richardson says Bryant received many
accolades on and off the basketball
court seemingly destined for greatness
from a very young age he apparently
started playing basketball at the age of
just three his father was also a
professional player moved over to Italy
when he was was a child because of his
father's career that took him over there
so I think that again helped him have
that kind of global take on the game the
fact that he grew up and spoke Italian
went back home to the States
at the age of 17 he signed an NBA
contract and when he played his first
games in the NBA he was at that time the
youngest player ever to play in the NBA
league he's decided to skip college and
not go through that process and when
you've come into the game at such a
young age it can often be so difficult
to then actually capitalize on that all
that young potential but he did just
that he stayed with the LA Lakers for
two decades he won five NBA
championships and also want to Olympic
gold medals and I think those Olympic
gold medals maybe not as important so
fans back in the States but in terms of
taking his sport to that wide global
audience really important to how
basketball is now perceived and all over
the world